il ya un train de payer
oui mais là où il parcourt l eau mais il
s'est cramé 6,7 au coin
vous avez entendu trois champs
différents trois langues différentes et
trois univers différents
j'ai grandi avec de la musique et la
musique a fait beaucoup pour moi ça une
grande part dans ma vie et la musique
écouté mes parents celle que j'écoutais
enfants et que je continue à découvrir a
eu un rôle très important lorsqu'on
entend de la musique on peut être touché
par la mélodie par la musicalité des
mots ou l'interprétation mais en tant
que chanteuse interprète
j'ai réalisé que pour pouvoir chanter
juste et chanté dans l'intention il me
fallait comprendre les mots il était
devenu nécessaire d'aller à la rencontre
des langues
la rencontre entre les langues et le
chant ce que je souhaite partager avec
vous aujourd'hui
alors je suis d'origine togolaise et
j'ai grandi à paris est assez
naturellement mes oreilles ont été
habitués à entendre le français le
mineur qui est la langue vernaculaire du
sud du togo par les permis
r et le kabyè qui est la langue du nord
du togo parler par mon père le mina et
le cab hier ont des sonorités aussi
différentes que le russe et l'italien
est chez moi à la maison c'était comme
une sorte de valse de langue entre le
français le mina et le kabyè et chaque
langue a eu un rôle important
assez naturellement mes études ont été
orientés vers à l'apprentissage de
langues
parce que j'avais besoin de comprendre
comment les langues s'articule leur
ossature leur morphologie et le sens des
mots jacques lang apporte sa couleur
vocale sa couleur musicale sa couleur
rythmique également alors si je commence
par le français c'est une langue qui me
tient à coeur puisque c'est ma langue
maternelle est le français est une
langue monocorde mais ça veut pas dire
monotone je me souviens encore des
poésies a prises lorsque j'étais enfant
et lorsque je récitais les poésies je
voyais comme comme des tableaux en
écoutant les mots de verlaine ça disait
les sanglots longs des violons de
l'automne
blaise mon coeur d'une langueur monotone
tout suffoquant et blême
quand sonne l'heure je me souviens des
jouets anciens et je pleure la langue
française c'est comme un paysage de
collines et les mots ruisselle et les
mots coulent les phrases cool
il n'y a pas de rupture il n'y a pas de
pic
si on parle maintenant des langues
tonale les langues tonale sont comme le
vietnamien ou le mandarin et c'est
vraiment différent de la langue
française une langue tonale c'est une
langue dans laquelle
la prononciation des syllabes est
soumise à un ton précis et un ton en
langue c'est une auteure déterminée d'un
son si on change le ton on change le
sens si par exemple en mandarin je vous
dis le mot ma il s'agit de la mer la
maman si je vous dis ma c'est le cheval
m'a le verbe insulté ma le mot chambre
donc je je voulais porter votre
attention sur le fait que en changeant
le ton ça change le sens du mot je vous
laisse imaginer la complexité d'autres
langues comme le vietnamien qui possède
citons le taï qui possède 5 ton mail
avantage en musique c'est que de par la
richesse tonale de ces langues
certains musiciens asiatiques ont
l'oreille absolue
ils sont sensibles aux variations de son
et se sont aussi d'excellents musiciens
dans les instruments à cordes en
m'éloignant des langues asiatiques
je me dirige vers l'anglais par
l'anglais a beaucoup compté dans ma vie
dans la musique
j'étais passionné par l'histoire du
peuple afro américains et de toute la
musique qui en découle le negro
spiritual le gospel l'assaut de jazz et
le blues et dans la langue anglaise j'ai
découvert des intonations chantante
vibrante pétillante et swing comme dans
celle django reinhardt samedi
bombardier rapide fort d'un bon bon bon
ma route se poursuit en allemagne et
dans la langue allemand je découvre une
langue étonnante une lampe créative
un peu comme un lego en allemand on a la
possibilité de compiler des mots pour
pouvoir désigner un objet ou un concept
et avec la langue allemande j'ai aussi
découvert une autre capacité d écoute de
par sa syntaxe
il peut y avoir un ou plusieurs groupes
verbale qui se trouve à la fin d'une
phrase longue et pour comprendre la
phrase il faut être patient il faut
attendre la fin de la phrase on ne peut
pas interrompre le flot des mots comme
en français est la langue allemande a
beaucoup été utilisé dans les opéras et
l art est la langue d'expression des
leaders de schubert et qui dit de façon
très douce si j'étais un oiseau je
resterai sur cette branche et je
chanterai pour elle tout l'été à gagny
en seine-saint-denis
magnifique
le russe le russe je reste sous le
charme de cette langue accentue l de
pouchkine avec tous les personnages de
tchekhov de gogol qui lutte contre
l'oubli et le russe a comme un goût
aigre-doux saadé intonations beaucoup
plus intérieure est beaucoup plus ronde
que le français est l'accent tonique en
russe est variable et ça conditionne la
prononciation des voyelles et si on
prend par exemple les paroles du poète
ukrainien greben cas dans ces fameux
yeux noirs aux yeux noirs lieu sublime
est ravageur odjidja lié au churn y est
ocz istrati et aux gauchers
les craintes liées à gremio où je
m'envole au japon le japon avec ses
syllabes courtes ouvertes et aériennes
et la langue japonaise reflète cette
recherche de de minimalisme et
d'esthétique à l'image de son sac ou la
légendaire vous connaissez ça coule à
sakura yayo innocent iii me what à
suzuka qu'il y est il
il ya toutes ces autres langues
d'afrique du sud
lorsque la première fois j'ai entendu
l'hymne d'afrique du sud
nikos ici que les lits africa en cinq
langues
en gros ça en zoulou en s'auto en
afrikaans en anglais là j'ai senti la
terre j'ai senti la puissance j'ai senti
l'ancrage et j'aimerais vous interpréter
un extrait de cet hymne et j'aimerais
vous demander de taper le point sur le
mans 10 juillet mais ça m'amuse auriez
tout corps aussi c'est quelle est
l'insulté la tina le soir bâlois you
more elle à bouloc un sécheur assayas ou
aux fins des sites d'une toile et même
seigneur ont aussi bloqué
c'est bloqué
aller à la rencontre des langues
c'est comme mélanger des épices c'est
comme marié des saveurs et c'est ravir
nos oreilles de sonorités exotiques
alors pour finir j'utiliserai les mots
de new fabris cuse pour vous dire irene
good bye bye la famille
donaldson
il n'aura wafi belle flamme travail
n'aura fille de sting dit non
à
ferme et douce